Maybe often tax
you introduce the points based immigration system
as per the manifested that both you and I stood on.
We've seen new immigration figures this week.
I mean that I
wateringly large.
Have we got to the point where the government
seems to have lost control of immigration?
So it's really important to differentiate
between the legal system
and rightly
you've mentioned the points based immigration system
and I do want to talk about this.
And then you got the illegal issue
which is obviously very contentious,
but I don't think
the government has handled that particularly well.
On the point space system
there are very,
very clear parameters
to help people come to our country.
Because on point space system
they come here to work.
So they have to be sponsors.
So it's all through employer LED schemes
and also the net contributors to Dick Shecker.
So, you know,
we can't just assume that people are coming here
and there's lots of free riding taking place.
They have to pay the immigration health surcharge
which is in the thousands of pounds.
Yeah, not just for them
but for their family members
and also their visas are incredibly expensive too.
And they're coming to contribute based on that system.
It is the sort of.
Is the resealing on it.
You relax for that to go as high as no
as anyone want.
So Jake, when I left the department last year,
which I left government,
you know, out Of out of
on my own terms.
Basically I chose to resign from government because
quite frankly,
if they're poor in antics
that took place in Westminster
with a lot of,
lot of our colleagues,
um, we actually put in measures
and we handed over to my then successor
what I used to call the automatic stabilizers,
which is a bit of a Treasury term.
Those are the leavers at
the Home Secretary
had to basically
reduce the number of people coming into the country.
So increases with the Migration Advisory Committee
on salary thresholds
for example,
um, which is really important,
you know, that has to keep on increasing
and we saw this previously.
If you don't do that,
you just have people coming in to do jobs
which quite frankly,
could be done by British people in the UK.
But they also have to be skilled and trained,
the other factor,
and I'm very vocal about this
and I was when Rishi Sunak was chancellor.
I'm very disappointed there's been no movement on this.
I believe we need a UK wide labour market strategy
because by having a point space system,
you cannot just rely on migrant workers coming in.
Despite the majority of this being quite, you know,
pretty high skilled
at the high end threshold,
so they are net contributors.